una travesía en vano
432 migrantes fueron repatriados a irak
perdiendo sus posibilidades de llegar a
territorio europeo luego de pasar varias
semanas en el frío y la hostilidad de la
frontera entre belarús y polonia
el ejército bielorruso te dice que te
llevarán a polonia pero al contrario te
llevan a lituania los vi los rusos te
quitan la tarjeta sin del celular te
dejan en el bosque y te dicen que te
vayas si vives o mueres es tu problema
nos quitaron el agua y nos echaron al
bosque pasamos tres días en el bosque y
no supimos si podríamos regresar a la
ciudad o no realmente sufrimos mucho
tras su encuentro en varsovia los
ministros del interior de polonia y
alemania ofrecieron ayuda humanitaria
pero no visados
tizimín sintió instruments estas
personas son los instrumentos de una
estrategia perversa y por eso hemos
dicho de acuerdo con nuestros valores de
la unión europea que ofreceremos
asistencia y ayuda a estos refugiados lo
que no haremos es acoger a los
refugiados no nos inclinaremos a la
presión y decir que estamos llevando
refugiados a los países europeos
la unión europea' que usa belarús de
haber creado deliberadamente la crisis
migratoria al permitir que emigrantes de
medio oriente cruzarán su territorio
para alcanzar polonia y lituania en
represalia por las sanciones impuestas
contra el gobierno de alexandr
lukashenko por sus políticas que van en
contra de los derechos humanos con la
proximidad del invierno los campamentos
de migrantes ubicados en la frontera
están siendo desalojados las autoridades
bielorrusas los están ubicando en
instalaciones temporales el resultado de
la dura situación por la que pasan ha
terminado para algunos de ellos en la
muerte este jueves por ejemplo fue
enterrado en polonia un migrante de
origen africano
tenía alrededor de 30 años era un hombre
afro eso es todo lo que podemos decir
según organizaciones humanitarias de
polonia ya serían 12 los migrantes que
han fallecido entre ellos un menor de un
año